let's bring in speaking of bringing
along with us let's bring in lara trump
fox news contributor good morning laura
good morning i agree with you ainslie
the carolinas are beautiful places to be
i'm from north carolina you're from
south carolina and will i'm in florida
right now so i fully appreciate the
statement you just made don't come down
and bring the the reason you left your
state to our states now please do not do
that exactly our kids have to stay in
masks do you miss new york
miss the old new york sometimes but i
gotta tell you when it's snowing up
there in a blizzard it's really nice
down here in florida so pretty happy
about this decision right now yeah you
could always go in the subway uh it's
always safe down there if the snow gets
too hard hey uh laura a couple of things
it's uh today we're going to find out
about the inflation report uh and it
looks as though they are bracing
themselves at the administration because
they're already over seven percent when
he took over the country the president
united states was at one percent some of
the things are out of his control some
aren't overall the real clear average of
the major polls has him under 40 percent
which is behind where president trump
was at 42 at this point way behind
president obama as well as president
bush what do you think it says knowing
that most media gives him a pass on just
about everything including his
son
and all his international
entanglements
yeah well uh there's so much to unpack
there brian i mean how long do we have
for this segment i could talk about this
all day uh no one i don't think is
surprised to see that he is polling so
low because although the media tries to
cover up for joe biden although they've
been doing it since the campaign since
they let him campaign out of his
basement didn't press him on very much
of anything
people are starting to feel the negative
impact of joe biden being president you
know you go to the grocery store
everything's more expensive you go to
fill up your car that's more expensive
these days too and i think it's become
increasingly frustrating for people to
see that so many of the issues we have
in america right now were caused by joe
biden and if he wanted to fix them he
could look at the southern border all
you have to do joe biden is go back to
the trump era policies and the border
would be solved for you all you have to
do is do so many of the things that
donald trump had put in place open back
up the keystone xl pipeline and bring
our gas prices down make us energy
independent again and not reliant on
foreign energy this stuff seems very
basic i think and when average people
out there start to feel it and they
start to see that something could be
done about the issues we're facing in
america right now yet they are not they
are actually going in the opposite
direction in the wrong direction for so
many people um they're really frustrated
and so yes the polling is very low but
it is really concerning brian that no
one is calling him on it unless you tune
in to fox news
hey laura you think about how he's going
to how his administration how his
political team is going to try to
recover from these types of numbers what
will they do to try to inflate those
numbers and my suspicion is when you
look at these states beginning to roll
back their mass mandates their coven
mandates that by the time we arrive at
the state of the union joe biden will be
taking credit for putting covid in the
rear view mirror he will suggest that
his policies
did exactly that allowed us to exit the
pandemic the question i think i have for
you and for the american public at large
is will they buy it will they buy that
the biden administration and blue state
proposals are what delivered us from
kovid because my bet is that's what
they're banking on to reinflate those
numbers
yeah well i think you are spot on on
that why is it that nothing has changed
science-wise why is it that we have
known for a long time the efficacy of
masks or lack thereof yet these onerous
mandates have stayed in place all of a
sudden
now they're rolling them back and in
states so many of these states that are
rolling them back why not take them out
now they're waiting another month to do
this so yes i think that they are
hopeful that they can take full credit
for letting us go back to normal for
bringing us back to normal life um as it
relates to covid and look i don't know i
hope the american people are smarter
than that i think they are banking on
people being just so fed up with it and
so happy to have their freedoms back in
some capacity that it will reflect in
their poll numbers but you can't escape
the other things the things we just
talked about the way everything is more
expensive the way life is harder for so
many people so look unless they can get
a handle on those things they might feel
like they get a win here with allowing
people not to wear masks anymore thank
you so much
but i don't know that it's going to be
effective i think they're very helpful
kids
kids yeah and many of these blue states
exactly brian and many of these blue
states the kids still have to wear masks
to school and on the playground they're
not allowed in restaurants unless they
show a vaccine card and they have to
wear their masks you know to get to the
table and people are just ready
ready to let go of all of these
regulations and the blue states are
really affected and i think these
democrats are seeing because they're
worried about the midterms you have
congressman jim cooper he's saying he's
not going to run again listen to this
he says as usual democrats are not alert
to future dangers the biggest danger we
face in an off-year election after we
won the white house is the 100-year
trend toward the other party
redistricting is small potatoes compared
to that historical trend their strategy
is blind hope and we have got to get
this formula right the democratic party
in tennessee is basically facing
extinction your
thoughts yeah i think he's right and
that doesn't just apply to tennessee it
applies to a lot of states but this is
what happens ainsley when you prioritize
woke initiatives on things that the
small minority of people in the major
cities care about and you completely
ignore the rest of the country you know
we call it in politics flyover country
and that's because you don't get a lot
of money from the middle of the country
your donors are on the coast they're in
los angeles and they're in new york and
a lot of politicians just fly over the
middle of the country and totally ignore
people and that's exactly what you've
seen happen their needs are not being
met they don't do not feel at this point
like they're being heard anybody ever
wonder how a billionaire real estate
tycoon like donald trump related so well
to average people in america it's
because he got out there he talked to
them he traveled the country and he
listened to them very different than
what you see happening right now people
feel like they're not being heard like
nobody cares and so i think that's
exactly right i think it's going to be
really bad for their party you know i do
think it's going to be who's going to
heal their rift quickest yeah the big
story today chuck schumer joe manchin
are at odds that means nothing gets done
in a 50-50 senate and on on the
republican side mitch mcconnell and
president trump at odds kev mccarthy has
no idea what to do so this could be a
unforced error on the republican side
unless they get together what could they
do to get together who makes the first
move
well look i i think a lot of uh what's
going to happen will be determined by
the midterm elections i think the people
of this country brian are so fed up with
what they've had to deal with over the
past year they've seen how bad it is
under democrat rule and it is not good
for anyone in america so you start with
the midterm elections and look hopefully
we take back the house and the senate on
the republican side and actually start
making some changes that are going to
help people um you know in terms of the
tip for tap politics we'll have to let
that all play out but i think the
american people are going to speak up
resoundingly come november 2022 this
year and say enough is enough and we
want to take our country back and we
know that the republicans have the plan
to do that obviously the democrats have
failed at every level
you brought up laura what made president
trump resonate with people from quote
unquote flyover states as someone who's
from a flyover state i think we can and
should analyze that for honestly decades
to come there should be honest books
written about what happened there in
that time frame but i know this from a
substantive level one of the issues that
resonated with americans is president
trump's focus on immigration so let me
pivot to that in this respect two
five-year-old girls were found crossing
the southern border united states alone
just giving an illustration
to the humanity behind this issue the
human rights crisis behind this issue
but here is the point of politics and
substance in what works i want you to
take a look at the change in the mission
statement from the u.s citizen and
immigration services from the trump
administration to now here's how their
mission statement read before u.s
citizenship and immigration services
administers the nation's lawful
immigration system safeguards its
integrity and promise by efficiently and
fairly adjudicating requests for
immigration benefits while protecting
americans securing the homeland and
honoring our values that was the mission
statement
in the trump era
immigration department now it reads as
follows uscis upholds america's promise
as a nation of welcome and possibility
with fairness integrity and respect for
all we serve no mention of lawful
immigration no mention of protecting
americans or our borders
laura what do you think of the change
well they can't talk about lawful
immigration well because that's not what
we have happening at our southern border
it is so obvious it just smacks you
right in the face that they are allowing
lawlessness to reign down there they do
not care about the laws of our country
because it is a fully open southern
border you just talked about these two
five-year-old girls how many times do we
have to see this happen people know if
you come to america illegally right now
you can stay if you send your kids
illegally to america right now they can
stay it doesn't matter the this journey
up to our southern border through mexico
through central america is so dangerous
a third of women are sexually assaulted
the fact that we have young children
traveling by themselves right now in the
middle of winter is absolute insanity
and if this had happened under the trump
administration could you imagine the
focus on these two young girls by the
mainstream media yet guys i bet we are
the only people that bring it up today i
bet no other outlets will even touch
this it is despicable it is horrible for
these people it is horrible for america
so yeah well they can't even keep the
same statement mission statement in
place because it's not applicable right
now right uh okay laura stay right there
i want to bring this story in the white
house bracing for a brutal inflation
report as i indicated earlier americans
feeling the effects as we gear up for
super bowl sunday madison all worth with
our sister network fox business joins us
live from new york hey madison
good morning ainsley so the cpi report
which is going to show us just how much
more things are costing us today that
comes out in less than 90 minutes but
you don't need to wait until then to
know just how much more these items are
costing us and ahead of the big game on
sunday some of your favorite super bowl
items they're just gonna cost you more
no one knows it better than john of dan
and john's wings because wings have
really gone up in price so john tell me
what have you noticed about the cost of
your wings and then how have you
adjusted the prices for your customers
to compensate
well unfortunately we've had to raise
the prices
our cost has gone up in some instances
like four times so we've had to pass
that on to the customer we haven't been
able to do it fully as much because it
would just be an outrageous price if we
were to charge our normal margins
formula wise but
in general we've just had to raise the
prices and that's
something everyone's had to deal with
so tell me what were you charging you
know in 2019 and what are you charging
today and then you mentioned even with
that price hike it's still not getting
you the same margins that you were
getting two years ago yeah that's right
i think uh we were somewhere around 65
for a 50 piece we do like a 50 piece
wing kit for super bowl and this year
we're 99.99
and even with that you're still not
taking home the same margin exactly even
with that it still is tough yeah okay
and so obviously wings that's one of my
favorite parts of the meal but that's
not the only thing you eat the super
bowl there's lots of sides as well i
want to show you guacamole or more
specifically avocados this is my
favorite part of the super bowl size i
also love it on my salad avocados a year
ago cost you less than a dollar and
today it's going to cost you a dollar
24. and if all this makes you want to
have a drink before 7 30 a.m ainsley
unfortunately the average cost of
alcohol up four percent compared to last
year so we're not expecting good numbers
from cpi expect to pay big bucks this
sunday
madison our lunch time starts at 9 a.m
right harley and i
that
yeah not for me we're going to come join
you
angel will pay whatever it takes when it
comes to alcohol we know that just ring
it up right and you can write it off
right work related
we were racing each other to see which
one of us could throw the other under
the bus on the alcohol i've really tried
to get it changing you as quickly as oh
really okay that's too bad brian's
vendors are gonna be a little more
expensive now
okay fine you said it anyway all right
got it out well thank you madison for
that report let's hand it over back to
lara lara what's your reaction to this
because when he started in office
inflation was a little more than one
percent and in december it was seven
percent we're expecting even higher than
that for january
yeah well joe biden said that you know
he wouldn't raise taxes look we know
giving away free money has consequences
this is one of those consequences people
are paying more for everything across
the board and you know they have this
number of seven percent and you know
we'll see what they come out with today
but if you actually go to the grocery
store if you actually go out and buy
things it is far more than seven percent
that things are up at the grocery store
some things are up 25 50
it is much more than seven percent and
so they use uh you know this scale and
the way they rate things and they take
some items out but those are items that
actually impact people every single day
so
look unfortunately i don't know the end
to this i don't know that there is an
end in sight because there's absolutely
zero being done by this administration
to curb uh inflation rates and i assume
it's going to continue to go up uh just
another reason that people are looking
forward to november of 22 and november
of 24 as soon as they can get there to
bring this full circle i think you're
exactly right no matter what type of
pivot they try to make at the state of
the union as long as that number goes up
his approval rating goes down right not
much you can do about that and we'll see
what happens at covet 19. laura thanks
so much thanks laura